>>All right, everybody listen up.
>>Narrator: When Barry Guilliot
speaks, his students listen.
>>Barry: So you're all able to leave
a legacy for our seventh-graders
for next year by planting
these seeds.
>>Narrator: It could be his
imposing 6-foot, 5-inch frame,
or it could be his
impressive background.
>>Barry: I was a bouncer in a
barroom while I was in college
in a popular place on Bourbon Street,
and I was a sergeant in the Army
for five years, and I
figured, after all that,
it really prepared me just perfectly
to be a middle-school
teacher [laughs].
>>Narrator: Mostly, people listen
to Guilliot because they've come
to believe in his crusade
to transform education
through service learning.
>>Barry: Stick your
finger down in the hole
and drop both seeds in there.
Cover it up good.
>>Narrator: At Hurst Middle
School in Destrehan, Louisiana,
his seventh-grade students
learn about the environment
by preserving part of
it, their own backyard.
>>Barry: This is a project
called Coastal Roots,
and the Coastal Roots is to help
the kids appreciate their wetlands
and give them a feeling of
ownership by doing something
to help stop the wetland loss.
One of the key ways of doing
that is by planting trees.
Having the kids being able to grow
the tree from seeds just makes
such a big difference to them.
They can see how it all
starts from this little thing.
Plus, that's what we have
to teach them anyway.
Everything that we do has
to be standards-based.
If it's not standards-based,
we don't do it.
So not only are they learning,
but they're also helping out.
They're making a difference,
and that, in middle school,
where they're really trying
to figure out who they are
and where they're going, being able
to be a positive, contributing member
of the community, I
think, is so important.
>>Narrator: Guilliot started the
Wetland Watchers program in 1998
after seeing the educational value
of a service-learning trip he took
with seventh-graders to the
nearby LaBranche Wetlands.
His students now plant trees,
monitor water quality...
>>What's our temperature reading?
>>26 and a half.
>>Narrator: ...and educate
others about the wonders of
and the threats to their ecosystem.
>>Student: Hi.
Welcome to the Louisiana
Wetland Watchers.
Today we will talk about
the American alligator,
which is native to Louisiana.
>>Narrator: The program started
with meetings to gain the support
of a few local businesses
and government agencies.
>>Man: The feedback I get from
our new business partners is,
"This is amazing!
I wish I had known about it sooner."
>>Narrator: Today the program has 35
partners who donate time and money
to the project's yearlong
activities, which culminate
in a Wetland Celebration at
the end of the school year.
>>Kimberly: We initially started
off with roughly five volunteers.
We're now up to fifty
this year that solely work
with the LaBranche Wetland Watchers,
which is absolutely incredible.
>>Man: How about this
area right through here?
>>Louisiana.
>>Man: Louisiana, exactly.
>>Lorel: When I go out
there with the students
and I see them throwing their
nets in the lake and I'm like,
"One of those children are
going to fall into that lake,"
but they haven't yet and
hopefully they never will.
But I think it's just
important for them
to get involved in the whole lesson.
You know, not just to read about
it, not just to hear from teacher
about it, but to actually live it.
>>Narrator: Even in the classroom,
learning involves hands-on activity.
>>Barry: Have you all ever
seen an alligator before?
Do they have sharp teeth?
Ooh, does he nip at you?
>>Narrator: Seventh-graders
become experts in a subject
by sharing their knowledge
with preschoolers.
>>Girl: This is an
Australian Bearded Dragon.
He's native to Louisiana, and if you
want to touch him, you can touch him
with two fingers on his lower back.
>>Kurt: This represents the
scales of the alligator.
Hard, tough, this is to keep it
away from its natural predators.
>>Narrator: Fun is also a key
part of the learning process,
as in this illustration
of alligator adaptations.
>>Kurt: Please stick
out your left hand.
I said "left."
>>Students: [Laughter]
>>Kurt: Okay, you need to spend
a little more time at school.
Now, the hand is webbed
on an alligator.
>>Kurt: This has probably been my
favorite class in my school so far
because it's the one that's
been the most interactive
and most interesting to me.
>>Waggle your tail.
>>Kurt: I've been able to learn
a lot more through these programs
than I probably have sitting
behind a desk copying notes off
of a chalkboard.
>>Okay, they use that big old
tail to sway it back and forth,
and it shoots it through
the water like a bullet.
>>Kurt: Mr. Guilliot is probably one
of the best teachers you can get.
He's kind of like a big kid, and
he'll do the activities with you
where you can see firsthand
the right way to do it
and the fun way to do it.
>>Barry: Good job, guys.
Now keep up the good work.
>>Narrator: Even in
the face of gloom,
Guilliot maintains
his sense of optimism.
When a downpour forced the
cancellation of a field trip
to the wetlands, he
asked his team of experts
to bring their exhibits
to the school.
>>Barry: All right, we
got a special treat here.
>>Narrator: The rainfall
even provided a rare treat.
>>Barry: Christian
caught this outside
of his house in the flood yesterday.
Even though he looks like a snake or
something like that, he's amphibian,
and Miss Cheryl is going to tell
you all about him right now.
>>Cheryl: It's called
an amphiuma, okay?
>>Barry: And you know
what's neat about teaching
like that is assessment occurs
in so many different ways.
If I'm just lecturing, I can
look and see who's still awake,
but I can't really see
who's understanding.
>>Student: Oh, so, he's black on
the top and white on the bottom?
>>Cheryl: That's right,
just like a lot of fish.
It's a type of camouflage.
>>Barry: When we're busy jumping into
it and they're fooling with stuff
and moving it around
and all that, I can see.
I can go over and ask them,
"By the way, what is that?"
>>Barry: Why would it be white
on the bottom and dark on top?
>>So it could probably hide itself.
>>And looking up, it
probably blends with the air.
>>Cheryl: That's right,
blends with the sky.
>>Barry: When you're looking
down, it looks like the mud.
If something's underneath and
looking up, it looks like the light.
Very good.
>>Barry: And that's an
on-the-spot assessment right there.
You see, do they understand
it or not?
>>Man: What would you all think
would fall out of the water first?
>>The heaviest.
>>Narrator: Guilliot sees the
value of having more than one voice
of authority in his classroom.
>>Man: Now, you can actually see the
particles of sand with your bare eye.
>>Kind of like little crystals.
>>Barry: As I know I'm not a soil
expert, where I can call in my ag
and forestry guy from
Louisiana Ag and Forestry.
He's been studying dirt for 15 years.
I understand that they have all these
experts out here that are willing
to come in and work with my
students, and I want to use
that so my students are
getting the benefit of this.
>>Milton: If you look at the first
picture, you see nothing but water,
and as we've progressed, you can
see now where you have the land.
>>Milton: You can learn an
awful lot from a textbook,
but if you can show
them different things,
it's so much more enlightening,
and a lot of these kids, you know,
you can just see their
eyes open up and say, "Ooh.
Ah. Oh, look at this!"
So, hey, you know you're
getting to them.
>>We're going to have a beautiful
park out there, and nobody's going
to realize that hey,
that was once a lake?
>>Milton: If a little project like
this can have such an impact on them,
maybe this will ring true
to them and they'll say,
"Hey, something can be done."
>>Barry: The factors
that affect pH levels...
>>Narrator: For Guilliot, empowering
students is the most rewarding part
of the job.
>>Acidic rainfall.
>>Barry: One of the essays
I read said, "If the animals
and plants could talk, I think
they would say we're their heroes
because that's the way I feel when
we do our work in the wetlands."
And it just, you know, it hits you.
As a teacher, you say, "Oh, my God.
Something that I designed made
this kid feel like a hero?"
And I was like, "Man,
that is just so cool."
And, gosh, even if they don't
remember an adaptation for an animal,
if they just remember that feeling,
then I feel like I've been
successful, and I really love
that responsibility as a teacher.
I don't want to be a principal.
I don't want to be a superintendent.
I want to be a teacher where I deal
with these kids every
day down in the trenches.
And I love watching the light go on.
I just love it.
>>-That's perfect.
So you all do that for every
corner in that graph, okay?
Good job, guys.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.